brace yourselves because nois Antonio
doesn't look like this anymore yeah he
looks like this and we may not be okay
oh my god you didn't oh but I did the
Internet's boyfriend showed off his
fresh new buzz cut and an instant story
on Tuesday with the caption I'm right
here
yeah and we repeat still not okay no
event took the liberty of softening the
blow by giving us a shirtless video of
himself watching his cat drink out of a
faucet to no surprise his fans took to
social media to mourn the loss of those
famous curly locks that we just all fall
in love writing things like why would
Noah Santonio cut his hair it's already
been a long week and police say you cut
your hair for a booty roll or something
not that you decided to get rid of it
for fun it's unclear on why the star
decided to make the change however this
isn't the first time no has experimented
with some of his looks I kind of just
don't even really look at it back in
September he caused an uproar after
dyeing his facial hair blonde with fans
writing you know you're really going
through something when you bleach your
beard and well it's unclear why Noah
shaved his head it could be for his
upcoming movie role as he-man in massive
the universe which is set to be released
in March 2021 so what does that mean
what does that mean in human mo I can't
really tell you like what the tricks are
due to that hole at that whole game it's
a lot of work though is it I mean I
don't look like he-man and I need to
look like emails so it's like it's great
we're doing a we're doing a lot of hard
work and it's every single day but it's
really fun and I like regimen so it's
good but don't worry guys his curly
locks won't live forever on celluloid
next up fans can see now while on the
big screen in the upcoming Charlie's
Angels out November 15 really not
supposed to be touching things in here
unless you're supposed to be touching
things in here you're adorable
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]